good afternoon everyone thanks so much
for sticking around for this last Talk
of the day y'all are amazing and it is
an absolute honor to be a part of the
final strange Loop and to share this
stage with so many incredible speakers
and I do want to take a second before we
begin to thank Alex and all of the crew
and staff that have worked so hard to
make strange Loop happen and not just
this year but for so many years in the
past can we just all give them a round
of applause for doing
[Music]
that they're probably going to think the
talk is done in the Next Room but uh so
my name's Parker I'm currently a PhD
student in programming languages and
human computer interaction at UC
Berkeley and today I'm going to talk
about some of my research into building
programming tools for data journalists
and a bit more specifically I want to
share share how I think compilers can
open up new interaction models for
building interactive
Graphics but I do want to acknowledge
that putting together these three things
feels a bit odd like what does
journalism have to do with compilation
and AR compilers for transforming
programs and not charts and like what
even is a visual input and why didn't I
change this before submitting My Strange
Loop talk these are questions I ask
myself um it's a bit odd but I promise
there is some coherence to this and
really the central goal of this talk is
to present a new vision for what I think
programming interactive Graphics should
look like so today we live in a world
where published Graphics are these kind
of fixed entities that we can't really
inspect or remix or retarget or modify
in any way but I want us to imagine a
world where our Graphics become live
objects become these materials that we
can manipulate and interact with and
change and learn from and I think
compilers are actually the key tool to
make that
happen now before we dive into this
Vision let's get on the same page about
what data journalism
is so I think many folks here in the
audience might know it when they see it
say in something like this map from
propublica highlighting areas of the
United States with elevated cancer risk
caused by industrial air
pollution or this stirring and very
controversial visualization from The New
York Times when the United States CED 1
million deaths from Co
19 or in this graphic recently published
in the Washington Post showing predicted
changes in deaths linked to temperature
exposure over the next
Century so I think when many of us see
these examples we think that data
journalism is about telling stories with
data right about uncovering some kind of
hidden Insight trapped in a large data
set and certainly it is about those
things but when I see these Graphics I
just see a ton of programming like in an
absurd amount of programming that goes
into making these Graphics
work so I see things like messy data
sets that get pulled from Municipal
agencies or foyer requests or police
departments or academic journals all of
which need to get cleaned and
transformed and normalized and filtered
to actually produce some kind of output
graphic and I see you know computational
notebooks full of pandas and tidyverse
and map plot Live code or qgis projects
with dozens of layers generated by
different geospatial analyses and react
front ends and D3 animations and code
for scrolly telling and if you don't
know what scrolly telling is I guarantee
you you know what scrolly telling is
this is kind of all the rage in kind of
modern data
journalism so really as a computer
scientist and a software engineer when I
think about data journalism I think
about programming and when I think about
what data journalists do I think about
programming
but I do want to make a distinction here
that data journalism is not really just
software engineering right data
journalists have unique programming
constraints and contexts but our
existing programming tools really
weren't designed with them in mind so
what I've seen in a lot of my research
is that data journalists have largely
adopted the tools of data scientists or
bz developers or web developers or Cloud
infrastructure Engineers to do their
jobs but that's mostly been out of
necessity so they've become experts in
Cross browser quirks or optimizing
animations or rooting around in the AWS
console even though there's a lot more
to their work things like research and
ground truthing and Reporting and
interviews data Discovery copy editing
right when is the last time any of us
had to file a foyer request as part of
our software engineering
jobs so that's kind of the landscape
that we're working with the second thing
I want to mention is that the published
Graphics I showed you earlier are mostly
made in these National newsrooms that
have really big teams of data
journalists working on a single graphic
right so this is kind of the graphics
desk model and these teams do have a lot
of technical expertise but at a lot of
the local and um nonprofit newsrooms
that I work with for my research that's
really just one or two people trying to
pull off those graphics and it's
honestly just really difficult for teams
of that size to get anywhere close to
something published in the times or the
post
and so the kind of motivating question
behind a lot of my research is how can
we design and build programming tools to
support the working practices of data
journalists that's really what guides me
and I think the interesting part of this
question is actually kind of buried here
so I want to focus in on this idea of
working practices so if we're going to
make an intervention in the way that
data journalist program well we better
understand what's going wrong right now
with how they're programming so that's
what I did for most of the first year of
my PhD I spent 30 hours working with um
a group of data journalists social
scientists and Earth and climate
scientists just watching them program
and seeing what went wrong and the
context of this study um I was focusing
on how these users work with geospatial
data so my background is in cartography
before computer science so I'm really
interested to see how people struggle to
make maps with code and I ended up
writing a paper about this with my
adviser um this paper was published this
year at the ACM Kai conference um so if
you're curious about all of the details
I definitely encourage you to check out
the paper but for the purposes of this
talk I really want to focus in on just
two key observations from my time with
data
journalists so what I saw is that
examples form the foundation of how data
journalists work and in particular I saw
that many data journalists start by
trying to lift visuals Styles or
graphical forms from examples that they
see in the wild so these could be
examples from other newsrooms something
a colleague has made in the in the past
and then they typically want to try to
retarget those examples at a totally new
data set right and the goal is to see
hey does this particular visualization
work well with my
data in practice what this involves is a
lot of rooting around in the Dom or
looking at you know kind of transpile
JavaScript and trying to figure out how
the thing works and that takes a lot of
time um what I saw was that that reverse
engineering process was often just as
timec consuming as trying to build the
thing from scratch so not a super
effective
method the second thing I saw is that a
lot of data journalists spend time
actually sketching out visualizations in
design software so tools like figma or
Adobe
Illustrator and the goal with that
process is try to explore this pretty
wide design space of possible
visualizations without actually needing
to program
anything but again there's a problem
here which is that eventually they do
actually need to code the thing to
actually deploy online right and what I
saw happen more than once is that data
journalists were capable of Designing a
graphic in illustrator or figma that
they later just couldn't actually
reproduce in
code so as I started kind of seeing
these things happen in The Newsroom and
trying to put these two practices
together I realized that they kind of
felt like they had the shape of the same
problem which is that in both cases
these journalists were starting with
some kind of visual input an example or
a figma file or something like that and
trying to transform it into a
program and as someone who also studies
programming languages I immediately
thought could this be a compiler's
problem and like maybe like I think on
the surface of it um you know as a PL
researcher I'm kind of tempted to think
that like everything is a compilers
problem like right it's always the right
hammer for for every nail but I think
there's a big question here which is
like how are we going to compile from a
visual form to a textual symbolic
representation right so in the
traditional model of a compiler say
going from this uh Source program
written in Rust to this web assembly
Target program we have things like
alexir and a parser and maybe an
intermediate representation in a code
generator and maybe an assembler right
and in general this is a pretty well TRW
path we kind of know how to do this uh
you know Source program to Target
program
transformation but like what's going to
happen when our source program is
actually some kind of graphic right some
kind of visual
input so I think there are really two
key ideas that I've found in the course
of my research that make this possible
so the first is to think about
recovering or inferring semantic
information from that visual form that
we can represent symbolically right so
so in the case of something like a
graphic the idea is can we actually
distill kind of the essence of that
graphic into some kind of textual
representation and if we can do that
then maybe you know the steps of code
generation can kind of take over and we
can be on our
way the second idea is to map
interactions with a visual form into
program edits so it's all well and good
if we can get from one static graphic to
one program but in this Vision I have I
want data journalists to be able to
actually interact with that visual form
kind of like they would in figma and see
those interactions actually propagate to
the output program that gets generated
right so these are the two ideas that
have really uh been guiding most of my
PhD research up until this point and
we're going to dive deeper into both of
them through two systems that I've been
building so the first system is rivis so
let's dive into
that so in a sentence rivis is a
compiler from SVG subtes to data
visualizations that's my py
oneliner uh it's not totally accurate
though it's actually a compiler from SVG
subtrees to partial programs so these
are programs that get parameterized over
Columns of an input data set so the idea
is can we kind of take a graphic that we
find in the wild distill it into a
program that is parameterized to
accommodate totally new data sets so to
show this off um I'm going to do a demo
oh gosh here we go um and I'm going to
try to take this graphic published in
the New York Times and I'm going to try
to turn it into the graphic on the right
um which is uh a graphic visualizing um
some data about Antarctic penguins and
we're going to try to kind of capture
the visual form from that times graphic
um but Target it at this totally new
data set so that's kind of the
motivating question behind this can we
actually automatically retarget existing
visualizations at new data sets
all
right okay so let's go over to the
browser
here so I have this um article from The
New York Times kind of loaded up here so
the first thing I'm going to do is
actually go ahead and pop open my
browser Dev tools so we've
operationalize the Riz compiler to live
inside of Chrome extension so I'm going
to go over to the dev tools and over to
RZ and the next step is I'm going to um
actually enable this SVG selector so
this is going to turn svgs on the page
into live elements that I can select so
when I click on this particular
visualization we'll see that Ras has
actually generated some information for
us so it's inferred that this graphic is
a scatter plot and then it's also grab
some kind of useful geometric and
presentational attributes that are
present in that graphic and then down
below here we'll see that a program has
actually gotten generated ated and I'm
just going to zoom in to make that a
little bit more visible and what I want
you to uh notice about this program is
this kind of double question mark string
we have going on here so in a partial
program this is something called a whole
so these are going to correspond to
Columns of our data set so these are
going to be things that we actually fill
in once we upload um a new data set so
I'm going to pop over over to this
visualize Tab and the next step I'm
going to upload my own data set um into
Rez to start working
with um so go ahead and grab that
penguin.
CSV and we can see that the data has um
been loaded up inside the
extension and now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go ahead and actually
grab um this flipper
length and over here in this code miror
editor I'm going to pop in that column
name and then I'm going to go ahead and
grab the body mass to use on the Y
Channel
and then for fill and stroke we'll go
ahead and fill that in with
species all right and when we actually
go and run this program we'll see that
we get this output visualization that
kind of has the those same visual Char
characteristics as the times piece but
it's been retargeted at our data set of
penguins and what I really like about
this is that this code mirror instance
in here is actually live so we can start
modifying this program Say by adding
something like grid lines bumping down
the radius and let's bump up the stroke
width and maybe reduce that fil
opacity and if we do that we actually um
start to see those changes to the
program so we haven't actually left the
New York Times website and we haven't
actually really written any code
ourselves we've just kind of filled in
some holes with column names um so again
the idea that I really want to emphasize
here is we started from this fixed
entity of this graphic and we got to
this live object this program that we
can actually
manipulate all
right all right so to recap what we saw
there we started by actually identifying
a visualization to use as a visual input
we then passed that SVG sub tree off to
reviz reviz compiled this partial
JavaScript program for us and we use
observables plot Library as the
compilation Target here and then we
filled in the holes in the program to
produce that new output
visualization so that's kind of the life
cycle of the interaction with RIS but at
this point you might be thinking to
yourself like what actually happened in
the middle there like there's just kind
of a cooking show we got from you know
this input graphic into uh this Partial
Program so we're going to dive into that
and like many good things it all starts
with a
walk so once we pass off that SVG subury
to RZ RZ will actually start by visiting
each Dom node in that sub
tree and as it goes along to each node
it's actually reading the geometric and
presentational attributes off of that
node right things like you know the
radius of the circle or the fill or the
fill opacity and then it's also taking a
Peak at its computed Styles just in case
there are any kind of visual attributes
that don't show up on the Dom
node and then we store all of those
attributes from all of those nodes
inside of attribute sets and sets are
important here because they allow us to
um D duplicate any values that we see
more than
once then the next thing we do is
actually apply a set of predicate
functions associated with a given
visualization type so for something like
a bar chart we're going to expect that
you know the majority of marks in that
SVG are rectangles that they have
consistent width and that the X scale is
discreet so this is kind of a way of
encoding semantics about what a bar
chart is into a set of predicate
functions that we apply over these
attribute sets and then we start by
Computing the ratio of predicates that
return true for each visualization type
so for our example none of the
predicates associated with a bar chart
actually return true but if we try a
scatter plot we'll see that both of its
predicates return true something like a
strip plot two of three and then a
bubble chart just one of two so at this
point reviz kind of determines that hey
probably this thing looks like a scatter
plot right so once we've actually
inferred that visualization type we
merge it with those attribute sets into
this intermediate representation shown
here on the right so that IR very
compact really tiny pretty simple Json
object kind of distills a lot of
information about what that visual input
was into a really compact form so this
is what I would kind of call the front
end of the Revis compiler we've kind of
replaced parsing and Lexing stages with
our own kind of
analysis so now let's talk about the
back end of the compiler how we actually
get from that IR to a
program so we're going to start with
that ir and actually just an empty
program an empty string which we signify
with this idea of an evaluation hole and
you can really just think of this as an
insertion point for our generated code
going
forward and then we apply a set of
rewrite rules that transform key value
pairs in that IR into distinct program
fragments so we'll start off by looking
at this type scatter plot key value pair
and pass that into this eval type
rewrite rule with our current program
and out the other side will actually pop
a new program fragment kind of a rewrite
on that initial empty program and so we
just repeat this process for every key
value pair in the IR so next we're going
to pass that R attribute into eval geom
Adder alongside our kind of builtup
program and then out pops again a new
program fragment so we continue applying
applying this process for all um key
value pairs in that intermediate
representation kind of building up this
program with successive rewrites um
until we arrive at the final output and
there are some additional kind of
compiler passes we run here on the
generated code to do kind of higher
level things that are not just
straightforward kind of syntax
Transformations um but this is really
kind of the the key
idea so to sum it up the internals of
reiz um actually involve starting with
the input visual ation analyzing that
viz into um a collection of attribute
sets we then perform analysis on those
attribute sets to generate the IR we
then uh apply these rewrite rules to
perform the code generation that results
in our Partial Program and then finally
the user actually fills in those holes
in that Partial Program with columns
from their data
set so I think what's actually the best
part of this system is that IT addresses
a core challenge that data journalists
already face when they work with
examples right so we talked about how
they spend all of this time trying to
manually reverse engineer these examples
that they find out in the wild and apply
them to new data sets but of course that
reverse engineering process was just
really onerous it was a lot of time and
so Revis opens up a way for us to just
automatically compile those examples
into partial programs that are ready to
accept any new data set that they want
to
visualizes so that old process in my
observations with journalists takes kind
of on the order of magnitude of hours or
days and that RIS interaction can happen
in a matter of
milliseconds so to wrap up this section
I want to finish with a word from um
Mike bosok the creator of D3 definitely
one of my personal Heroes um and he had
this great piece about a year ago called
uh 10 years of open- source
visualization and it had all this great
wisdom for viz designers and he wrote
don't commit to a specific visual form
before seeing your data in it a given
visual form say the pie chart or tree
map isn't good or bad in an absolute
sense but it may or may not be
appropriate to your data in the specific
question you want answered the only way
to know whether a form is effective is
if it communicates you must put your
data in it and see and so that's really
what drives the design of Revis we want
to make it as easy as possible for data
journalists to see their data in as many
graphical forms as quickly as
possible all right
so for the second half of the talk here
I want to kind of focus in on this idea
of mapping interactions with a visual
form into program edits um and for that
I want to talk about
cardit so cardit is a system I've been
developing um for kind of this entire
year of my PhD it's a direct
manipulation programming environment for
interactive
cartography and to show off how this
works we're going to try a second demo
here we go
where um we're going to start from this
U this map published in the Washington
Post and I'm going to see if we can
achieve the same map purely through
direct manipulation uh no programming um
inside of cardo
kit all right so this is um the graphic
here this is by data journalist um Harry
Stevens who um I've been in conversation
with at the Washington Post and he was
kind enough to open source um the data
for this graphic so I'm going to pop
over into cardit um so this is running
at alpha. cardit dodev if you want to
give it a try and I'm going to start by
actually uploading that data set um from
Harry's
story and then we're just going to give
this layer a name um just to identify
it all right so our data has been loaded
up into cardit but something else has
happened in the background for us um if
we pop open this open editor uh what
we'll see on the right side is that um a
uh program has actually been generated
for us right so immediately we load data
into this tool and we get a program
already so this is a JavaScript Pro
program um using mapbox
gjs and you'll notice that as I start
zooming into the map moving around the
center um that these parts of the
program are kind of changing live um as
I'm actually interacting with the
program
output so um if I go ahead and click on
one of these polygons um I can start
doing just really basic things like
let's go ahead and uh change up the
stroke and reduce that width and we'll
see that those edits are starting to get
uh propagated over to the
program and I'm going to go ahead and
actually change the map type for this
visualization from kind of a simple fill
layer of polygons to a chloropleth map
so this is the map style that um Harry's
using in the story very familiar I think
to U many folks who have seen things
like election Maps right so we're
coloring these polygons by some kind of
data
attribute you can see that our program
over on the right has gotten um a bit
more complex there's kind of this new um
Step expression being introduced for um
actually coloring those polygons and all
these braks have been kind of derived
for us and I'm going to start making
some changes is so I'm going to choose a
different attribute for us to visualize
to match the story so again we see
changing the output changing the program
we're going to use a Jen scale to bend
the data this is kind of a good um
binning method to use for geospatial
data uh we'll pop that up to eight steps
to match what they have in the story and
then we'll go ahead and use that same
kind of purple green diverging color
scale um and actually swap
it Okay so we've done a a lot of edits
um to this map to get it starting to
look something like this uh Washington
Post piece um and now what I'm going to
do is go ahead and actually just copy
this
program and let's get
that all right and then I'm going to hop
over to my code editor I have just an
empty HTML CSS JavaScript Pro uh project
over here so the HTML file has uh a link
to the mapbox CSS tiny bit of custom CSS
and kind of just a reference to that
script tag and an empty div for the map
um so this is running at Local Host 8000
if I pop over here and uh refresh we'll
see it's really just uh an empty empty
web page at this point so I'm going to
paste in that code that CIT generated
and the last thing I'm going to do is
just replace that mapbox access token um
with my own and I'm using process. m uh
just so that I don't put my uh access
token on blast for the entire
internet all right and if we go over and
refresh um this page
here so we'll see that we have um an
exact reproduction of the map that we
were just working on in cardo kit um and
that kind of mimics what we were working
with uh from that Washington Post story
um but now what I think is so great is
like we have access to this JavaScript
program like we didn't actually write
any of this we just styled the map how
we wanted to inside of cardit but now we
have access to the program that we can
deploy on our own site or share with a
colleague or something like
that all
right cool so to recap the interaction
model here we started by just uploading
some data to cardit cardit then rendered
that data while actually simultaneously
generating a program for us and then we
started styling that data just through
direct manipulation we weren't actually
writing any code but the program was
changing from um from out from
underneath us and then we were able to
go ahead and copy that program and we
could have modified it further or
deployed it in a different
context and again at this point you
might be like how the heck does this
actually work like how did we get from
those interactions in that UI into
program edits like how did that program
actually appear
so the idea to start is that we map
those property controls in the UI again
to an intermediate representation so
this is a a quite a similar idea to Rez
and then whenever a user actually Alters
a property in the UI we just dispatch an
update to that IR so when I did that
transition from that fill layer to um
that corop layer we actually just
dispatching an update to the IR and
under the hood that would look something
kind of like this git diff so this is
this is a stateful object running inside
of this spell application but you can
see that the actual changes we have to
make to the IR are pretty minimal even
though kind of the visual form is
changing quite a bit in front of
us so once we've updated that IR um we
kick off code
generation and we start at the top level
of the program uh with dependencies so
we start determining hey what libraries
is this program going to need to
actually run so that's the
responsibility of this Cen Imports
function but I want to draw your
attention to uh these three other
functions kind of underneath so you'll
see that inside of this Cen Imports
function we have calls to other code
generation functions so these functions
will be responsible for generating new
program
fragments um and they'll actually Peak
at kind of distinct parts of that IR to
do that code generation so for the case
of something like Coden map what
actually happens is it generates its own
tiny program fragment that's responsible
for creating the map instance wiring up
event listeners um and starting to
actually load in some of the data so
expanded all the way out what this ends
up looking like is just a whole bunch of
code generation functions that operate
on specific pieces of that ir and then
they just kind of generate their own
program
fragments hand them back up to their
calling function and then the calling
function actually determines where in
that output program um should we
actually insert those program fragments
to produce a complete semantic
semantically and syntactically correct
um JavaScript
program and we uh have chosen Mbox gjs
as kind of the compilation Target but I
do want to note that the cardit IR is is
really agnostic here so we could have
just as easily chosen to compile to
something like leaflet another um
geospatial visualization library or D3
or map Libre or degl kind of the the
target here really doesn't matter
because the IR um is really quite
agnostic um to kind of which rendering
framework we use and while we're at it
we could have also chosen r or python or
any other programming language as the
Target right so I think that's kind of
what's powerful about this idea is we
kind of have one ir and many possible
compilation
targets so uh to recap the internals
here we exposed this direct manipulation
interface for map styling and then this
works by actually mapping um those
controls in the user interface to an
intermediate representation changes in
that UI correspond to changes in the IR
and then we perform code Generation Um
from the IR on every program change to
actually generate that output um
JavaScript program so again what I think
is great is this already fits with how
data journalists are working today right
we saw that they spend a lot of time
sketching these visualizations inside of
design software and the goal was always
to explore this pretty wide design space
um without code but once they actually
selected a design they still had to
reproduce that program at some point
right so I think what kit really opens
up is an ability for uh data journalists
to style Maps purely through direct
manipulation and kind of just get the
programs for free that are ready to be
modified or changed or deployed kind of
anywhere they want and again that whole
process um can happen in a few
milliseconds
all right so that's
caroet so now um to finish up the talk I
want to take a step back from kind of
the uh specifics of these two ideas and
these two systems to think about this
broader Vision I have of compilers for
visual input inputs like what does this
really get us and how does it actually
change things for data
journalists because beyond the actual
technical details and implementation
here I think there's a deeper way in
which this technique kind of changes how
we can think about building
Graphics um so to ground this last
section I'm going to tell you story
about my own experience learning to make
graphics so back in the winter of 2016 I
was a cartography student at Middlebury
College and I was spending a lot of
hours tucked away in the studio on
campus third floor of mardle bay
Centennial Hall in the dead of winter um
very good times uh and at that time I
was working with this amazing professor
Jeff howth um and I was trying to
develop the skills to pursue a career as
a newsroom
cartographer and when I asked Jeff for
advice he was like I have this theory
that the best way to develop the actual
aesthetic intuitions of a cartographer
is to start by working from examples
like try to reproduce the techniques of
the experts in your own
maps and so that's what I was doing most
of that winter I was studying things
like the line work in Harry Beck's
iconic map of the London Tube or the
Shaded relief of the great Swiss
cartographer Edward
imhof or the uh Innovative perspective
and projection warping of National Park
Service cartographer Tom
Patterson so a lot of those early days
were spent just trying to understand
what made these Maps work and how I
could bring some of these techniques
into my own map now what that involved
in practice was a lot of kind of manual
reverse engineering so I was using
computational tools at the time to do
things like lift color pallets out of
these Maps using my own shaded shaded
relief or um just purely rip off the
typographic choices to kind of use in my
own stuff or um you know to gauge
whether or not the visual hierarchy
between my base layers and my data
layers kind of had sufficient contrast
right so in short I was really trying to
distill the techniques of the experts
into my own
Maps but um as you imagine this process
was actually pretty onerous right I
could use these Maps as kind of design
inspiration um they could help me kind
of make aesthetic choices but they
didn't provide any actual guidance on
how to do the thing right so they always
felt kind of like these fixed static
objects that I was kind of probing as
best as I could to understand how they
worked but I couldn't actually like
remix or explore them or inspect them in
any way and it didn't change the fact
that at some point in this process
there'd be an empty illustrator file and
an empty qgis project just kind of
staring me in the face staring me to get
started so the reason I bring all this
up is because I think data journalists
today face the exact same challenge
where there's this gulf between some
kind of visual input that they're
working with and some kind of program
that would allow them to kind of Express
the
graphic and in the middle inevitably is
some kind of empty code base and an
empty JavaScript program kind of Daring
them to get started so really when I
think about compilers for visual ual
inputs I see them as tools for kind of
collapsing this Gap and for really
erasing um the space between a graphic
and its underlying program and that
really pumps me up because again I
mentioned earlier how our published
Graphics today are really these fixed
entities that we can't change or adapt
or remix without deep expertise and a
lot of
effort and of course the programs that
actually made those Graphics are are
always opaque to US unless the data
journalist chooses to open source their
work but I think with this technique
what we have is the potential to see
these Graphics as live objects and as
things that we can manipulate and
interact with and change um and I think
that has big implications not just for
how we think about developing Graphics
but also who we can Empower to start
making Graphics so our model no longer
has to be about starting from a blank
program and not all data journalists
have to be software Engineers kind of
going in at the back end of a codebase
um to to pull off some of this
impressive work and I think what excites
me most about this vision is that the
entire internet can become an
example so that's all I have for you
today um if you're interested in
learning more about these systems please
come talk to me I'd love to integrate
them into what y'all are working on
thanks so
[Applause]
much